says the capital is planning to set up
more than a thousand heating points for
the winter it's a precaution in case
Russian strikes disable heating systems
further waves of attacks have disrupted
power for many ukrainians we pairs well
have been Swift but aren't possible in
all areas around a third of Ukraine's
power stations are now in Ruins planned
blackouts are being used to try to
restore stability to Ukraine's troubled
grid
Elena and her husband Yara slav are
getting used to life with frequent
blackouts
the family who live on the outskirts of
Kiev have stopped counting how often
this has happened over the last few
weeks and with Russia increasing its
assault on Ukraine's energy
infrastructure the power cuts are
getting longer and more frequent
that's probably the worst because we can
stay with uh no
no water for some time we can stay with
having no hot food for some time but
with no
telephones on it's a little bit
uncomfortable
energy companies are publishing daily
schedules of planned blackouts to help
but they are struggling to stabilize the
grid yarislav says outages here can last
nearly 12 hours a day he and the family
have now decided to take a trip away to
escape
its energy facilities like this
hydroelectric dam in zapparicha the
moscow's missiles are targeting
according to the Ukrainian government
Russia has destroyed about 40 percent of
the country's energy infrastructure
step inside a nearby hospital and you
can see the impact on civilian life here
this doctor needing a headlamp to look
at an x-ray but in the face of Russia's
aggression there is some light amongst
the darkness this group of Volunteers in
Kiev many of them parents and children
are making candles to send to troops on
the front line to keep warm they call
themselves Ukrainian space
Intelligentsia and have already
delivered more than 3 000 candles to
soldiers in the trenches
the candles can be used to dry up a
trench cook food which is very important
boil some water and warm up these cans
come with a cover so you can close them
throw them into boiling water boil and
put them under your coat you can do this
many times
[Music]
both of these ukrainians remain strong
but for how long as this energy crisis
deepens challenging everyday life here
and hope for the future
DW correspondents Nick Conley is in the
Ukrainian Capital kiev for us Nick how
much longer can a Ukraine endure these
constant Russian attacks on critical
infrastructure Power and Water Supply
well that's the million dollar question
for now they are holding up
extraordinarily well
um if you look at the past few weeks how
things have gone basically every Monday
we've seen major attacks by Russian
cruise missiles and drones on the energy
infrastructure and that's not only power
but also obviously water supplies that
are dependent on electric pumps and
every time at least in cities here like
Kiev the supplies have come back on
within the space of a day or two
um the basically kind of emergency
blackouts are now at an end they're a
kind of planned blackouts to try and
kind of stabilize the grid if for now
Ukraine has enough electricity lots of
people millions of people have left the
country and most kind of heavy industry
isn't working right now so there is
enough power to go around but the real
problem is making it available to people
across the country and there is a sense
that uh you know the kind of resilience
in the system is now coming to an end
that they have been able to basically
roll with the punch for now but that is
becoming increasingly difficult
commissioner was in Keith yesterday what
kind of help did she offer
well she is saying that the EU is now
going to step in and try and coordinate
supplies of spare parts of all the kind
of equipment needed here to keep on
rebuilding Ukraine's Energy System after
every Russian attack we've heard in
recent days from Ukrainian officials
that basically their supply of all the
bits needed to keep the Transformer
stations to keep all the kind of grid
the kind of connections going that is
now at an end so basically Ukraine is
now fully dependent on foreign
deliveries for any future repairs and
she kind of made it clear that the EU
would coordinate the support between
International partners and make sure
that arrives here but let's obviously a
very uncomfortable situation for Ukraine
to be in having to kind of wait and to
make sure that those deliveries also get
here in time and not having the capacity
to really affect or do anything to
improve the situation it's really a
question of waiting and hoping that
those promises are really kept
now talking about International partners
and help from these Partners the
Ukrainian government says it needs even
more air defense systems to protect
itself from those attacks is key of
getting what it wants
well it is getting uh
systems uh air defense rocket defense
systems from Western Partners but not on
the scale they would want here in cave
we saw in recent weeks Germany
delivering that rst system system so new
so modern that the German Army doesn't
have it itself yet but for now it's only
one one system that is able to defend
one agglomeration one city but obviously
not enough if you think that this is a
war that is being fought over hundreds
and thousands of kilometers of front
lines more are expected to come the same
goes for American produced nasam systems
there's also been some promises recently
from Italy and France but also its
question munition even if you have these
systems do you have enough Rockets
enough mutations to really use them on a
daily basis I think the kind of fact
here is that no country in Europe and
you know across most of the world has
fought a war at this intensity for
decades so even if there is the
willingness to help most countries don't
even have these Rockets these Munitions
on you know already on hand in stock to
send Ukraine at the pace wanted here in
Kiev the W correspondent Nick Connelly
then kiev for us thank you Nick
now Russia says it has completed its
chaotic recruiting of 300 000 reservists
for its war in Ukraine and that no more
are needed for now but many Fair
President Vladimir Putin will indeed
call up more one man in Saint Petersburg
told us he's also received marching
orders despite being in a wheelchair
has been in a wheelchair for 26 years
a few days ago he was surprised to find
an army draft notice in his mailbox
his call-up means he's supposed to go
and fight in the war in Ukraine known in
Russia as a special military operation
[Applause]
United here's my name
my date of birth my address and the
order to report to the military
Authority on a certain day
I felt nothing but amazement and
certainty and how absurd the whole
system is all right
absolutely
[Music]
Amelia's disability is due to a mistake
made by doctors when he was a baby the
musician has never served in the Army
his condition should have been available
to drafting authorities in Saint
Petersburg
but to ignore the call-up letter he was
surprised when there was no reaction
from the military Ilya says his story is
not unique
thank you
dead brilliant I know a man who's
missing a leg and who also received the
same notice as me he then lost his only
leg in the Army his case is even clearer
than mine and I'm certain they knew
about his case
Russia's chaotic mobilization has been
reported on extensively via social media
elderly men men with disabilities and
men with serious chronic illnesses were
called up
some were sent home from the training
centers
despite the mobilization being declared
over there are fears there may be
another wave of conscriptions
is also worried about the future
life is more difficult now I worry more
about the future
I can't plan anything anymore at most
until tomorrow
an uncertain time for Ilya pekarev with
the fear of being drafted hard to shake